i'm gonna go grab a v's
okay come on
hello how are you man i'm good how are
you i'm good
you're here
yeah
chloe's dad
my ex
[Music]
this is the literally worst way that
justin could have ever met tim he
doesn't even know that we're friends
i don't know what to do so i run to the
kitchen because i'm literally physically
and emotionally running away just like
figuring it out amongst yourselves
i would say it's awkward
i think him being there is weird
because it's her house it's not tim's
house
so what'd you think about her uh her is
right here listening to the both of you
yeah i was just looking forward to
seeing who she was
you're just waiting
no
i just
you know she's out drinking just making
sure she gets home not really but you
never know that's true
well it's getting late
mm-hmm
so
i'm gonna head
on home good night
you want me to walk him out it's dark no
lights outside oh okay
i i guess so yeah
my life you're happy i was it that was
not i was trying to get kissed and you
blocked me
you will move
is your timer
oh me too
thank you for everything
you're very welcome
me sitting there staring at justin is
probably way more awkward for him than
it is for me because like i'm in my
territory like this used to be my house
i've known veronica over 15 years so i
want him to know
that like hey you're not gonna walk
around here with this girl
fungus i'm leaving oh yeah if you want
to follow me out i'll make sure you get
us kind of dark
such a
look
i'm like in complete shock like my brain
has not fully processed what's happening
it's just not the way i wanted the night
to end i'm really hoping that tim being
here didn't just completely ruin
everything with justin like that could
be it that could be the thing where he's
just like this is just too much weird
for me
peace out
[Music]
you